on va en discuter avec Ray Lalonde
analyste sportif ancien chef marketing
et vente aussi au Canadien de Montréal
donc vous suivez le hockey de très près
j'imagine que dans les dernières heures
vous avez suivi les rebondissements on a
l'impression qu'il quitte tous en même
temps les commanditaires pourquoi il y a
deux choses qui vont affecter ok Canada
puis l'avenir à court terme c'est la
pression publique et politique mais
surtout la pression financière à partir
du moment que les gros commentaires
TELUS Esso banque scotch canadienne qui
le fait de façon abrupte et permanente
c'est pas juste une suspension d'un an
là c'est fini et les autres
commanditaires secondaires finalement on
sera lit tous derrière eux ceux qui
restent en raison de ce questionnaire à
savoir comment ils vont expliquer ça au
grand public et à leur consommateurs
donc cette pression là qui représente le
l'argent des commentaires à peu près 45
50 % des revenus de Hockey Canada
au fil du temps Marie-Claude c'est
devenu quasiment un empire c'est
quasiment devenu une entreprise privée à
ce point-là à un moment où c'est une
gouvernance nationale de notre sport
national de notre sport préféré c'est là
qui ont perdu un peu le Nord si on veut
puis ils sont devenus trop mercantile ce
qui a causé beaucoup de réactions à
savoir est-ce qu'on protège l'argent ce
qu'on continue de générer des revenus de
ce niveau là puis qu'on a perdu un peu
le jugement qui était nécessaire en 2003
et en 2018 mais quand même l'histoire
des allégations d'agressions sexuelles
la gestion de tout ça le fond secret ça
fait quand même quelques mois qu'on
entend parler qu'est-ce que déclenché le
retrait des commanditaires au cours des
derniers jours dès le départ comme quoi
on allait suspendre on va voir un peu la
réaction des dirigeants
responsables imputable si ce centre avec
un peu d'empathie prêt à s'excuser
vis-à-vis le peuple vis-à-vis toutes les
circonstances et les parties prenantes
ils l'ont pas fait ils ont défié qui ont
défié les questions ils ont toujours un
peu relancé en disant c'est nous qui
sommes les mieux
préparés pour poursuivre le cheminement
de Hockey Canada ici nous qui sommes les
mieux équipés pour mener ce changement
là de culture d'entreprise c'est quand
même incroyable et c'est pour ça qu'on a
des réactions politiques jusqu'au
premier ministre mais justement on
dirait que personne est en mesure de
mettre l'équipe de direction de or de
changer les dirigeants qui décident au
final ce sont les branches ou les
provinces si on veut ok Canada a un
groupe de gestionnaires seniors qui sont
responsables de ces déboires là
actuellement au-delà il y a un conseil
d'administration le conseil
d'administration est aussi complice
parce que c'est sûr qu'ils savent tout
ce qui se passe depuis des années le
conseil d'administration est voté par
les branches ou les provinces si on vote
pour quelqu'un d'autre en novembre
décembre prochain lorsqu'il va avoir une
nouvelle élection pour le conseil
d'administration on pourrait avoir des
dirigeants qui pourraient
forcer les gens quitter ou quand j'ai
dit littéralement les dirigeants seniors
quotidiens alors ça peut pas venir du
gouvernement ça doit venir du conseil
d'administration est-ce que ok Canada
est menacé est-ce que on peut craindre
pour sa survie vous avez entendu le
Premier ministre Trudeau est-ce que
cette organisation pourrait mourir et
une autre renaître peut-être si on
continue de résister puis on pousse les
dirigeants et les différentes
commissions les différents les
différents responsables de l'avenir du
hockey alors qui va continuer les
lumières vont s'allumer dans les arts
amphithéâtre les araignées au Canada
bien sûr sauf que peut-être qu'on doit
revoir le modèle et la façon dont c'est
structuré c'est supposé est une
fédération c'est pas se poser d'une
business c'est bien de faire de l'argent
c'est bien d'en faire de la redonner
tout de suite puis de réinvestir mais
c'est pas le temps d'enrichir des
individus puisse garder des fonds cachés
pour venir en aide à des causes il faut
aussi dire que les causes
d'agression tout ça il y en a eu mais il
y a aussi des besoins de ces fonds là
pour des lorsque des joueurs se blessent
au Canada l'assurance ne cause pas
nécessairement tous les frais ça prend
de l'argent pour payer la différence
c'est un peu une portion de ce qui était
alloué pour ces sommes là et le
championnat de hockey junior qui doit se
tenir à la fin de l'année à l'ifax
Moncton c'est chapeautés par OK Canada
on peut s'attendre à quoi ça va être
intéressant de voir ce qui va se passer
dans les prochains mois parce que c'est
littéralement le lendemain de Noël que
ça débute c'est au Canada le Canada
c'est est devenu riche Marie-Claude avec
ses événements-là ça enrichit c'est des
millions de dollars qui rentrent à
chaque occasion que le Canada accueille
l'événement là est-ce que les
commentaires vont être là ben non pas
ceux-là en tout cas ça c'est sûr
deuxièmement ce que les diffuseurs vont
être là aussi parce que belle média
diffuse c'est une c'est une un élément
très important dans la programmation
programmation d'hiver de TSN par exemple
alors ils ont des questions à se poser
de ce côté-là est-ce que ça pourra
encore changer il reste encore un peu de
temps il pourrait y avoir des
changements la direction il y a des
témoignages qui s'enviennent encore donc
monsieur Bob Nicolson qui était le
président de 98 à 2014 lui a surveillé
supervisé il était au dessus de tout ça
au moment où beaucoup de situations là
sont arrivées lui on va le questionner
sérieusement suivant de Monsieur Tom
Reni l'ancien coach Avengers qui est
devenu le prochain PDG et encore des
gens qui doivent témoigner puis on peut
être des choses à dire puis on va
peut-être entendre encore des
révélations on aura peut-être une
occasion de s'en reparler donc
malheureusement merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI